je termine avec ceci que ceci c'est un
attelage une boule d'attelage qu'est-ce
qui se passe à l'heure actuelle c'est
que la boule d'attelage une fois qu'elle
est montée et bien pour la démonter faut
prendre des outils il faut prendre
toutes sortes de choses et c'est
extrêmement pénible ça serait en marche
du truc du tout oui donc et on s'était
dit ça serait bien de pouvoir la
démonter cette goutte parce qu'on s'en
sert pas tout le temps
et l'intérêt c'est que pour l'instant
vous ne pouviez pas le faire surtout
quand on s'est en général que deux trois
fois par an
il est possible c'est une
waouh il y a un petit un petit système
avec une clé qui vous permet de la
clipser sans aucun problème d'accord